[Musique]
les meilleurs produits de la région des
meilleurs joueurs de la place de paris
des camemberts au lait cru
tout un tas des spécialités comme
chantal vieux quant à lui entre deux
cantal jeunes vieux panne et en réclame
master d'origine
toute la gamme du des fromages de france
pratiquement lâché brut monsieur gêna
bonne choucroute la choucroute
alsacienne la choucroute est toute
chaude la choucroute au vin blanc mais
bien moche à la choucroute à la même
type où les chiots rappelle madame
chabot veine il a 42 ans je suis dans le
quartier ont fait du pain de campagne on
est toujours une bonne clientèle qui
vient à la maison depuis 42 ans
m
et m'ont accordé à chaque année
je vous remets toi
[Musique]
côté
or les zambiens balade c'est un de
calais oui parce que balade avec alain
ça veut dire se promener et balade avec
deux ailes ça veut dire c'est un poème
on lui octroie pourquoi tomber par terre
c'est la faute à voltaire je suis tombé
dans l'eau seul acteur bissau
sa faute
nous sommes ici à peu près de 42 43
pavillon cela représente environ
90 personnes il ya naturellement par le
va-et-vient des personnes vont faire
leurs commissions
et on se rend compte tout en se disant
bonjour et un petit mot par ci un petit
peu par là ça fait une bonne entente
générale et agréable en même temps il
nous permet d'être plus communicatif que
dans les immeubles que l'on peut
apercevoir aux alentours
c'est réellement de la petite ville de
campagne à sa petite ville plutôt que la
grecque campagne à paris quoi
[Musique]
dans la voix de muriel la jeune
chanteuse de belleville et elle nourrit
situe exactement l'ambiance qui existait
autrefois dans ce quartier qui était un
village et belleville était un village
alors qu'est ce qu'un village vers moi
je vais vous en donner une définition
c'est la mienne est paré je crois qu'à
s'applique d'ailleurs presque à tous les
villages de france
quand on voit une campagne française
voit toutes ces maisons groupées autour
de l'église autour peut-être lui-même
aussi que parfois il ya le cimetière à
côté c'est l'environnement du village
donc un village c'est d'abord un
environnement c'est un environnement
avec des maisons avec une architecture
avec des jardins parfois à belleville
comme c'était le cas avec des cours et
puis des arbres c'est un environnement
deuxièmement qu'est ce que c'est encore
c'est une population
il y avait une population béninoise qui
était une fabulation intégré depuis plus
d'un siècle et ensuite le troisième
volet du village c'est la manière de
vivre la façon de vivre et cette manière
de vivre était comment dirais je
le résultat est la symbiose de cette
architecture de cet environnement
et puis de cette population qui
s'habillaient d'une façon particulière
qui parlait d'une façon particulière qui
mangeaient d'une façon particulière et
nous avions aussi et nous à belleville
notre nourriture nous avions notre
manière de livres à nous et tout cela
c'est foutu tout ça c'est parti parce
que d'une part on a démoli plus de 75
hectares dont le bas de la rue de
belleville et du boulevard de belleville
à la rue rampal on a concédé une vieille
maison ont démêlé besson qui était
formidable des maisons qui étaient en
pierre de taille et que l'on aurait très
bien pu rénover on aurait très bien pu
leur apporter le confort nécessaire
on les a cassés être une façon
systématique d'une façon arbitraire
alors toutes les vieilles
toutes les vieilles cours avec les ars
vont en acier les arbres on a en a
retiré toutes les plantations
alors voyez cet environnement a disparu
dont nous a disparu alors quand à la
population la population les parties la
population les parties elle est partie
au cimetière elle a été évacuée
sinon à montreuil sinon à bagneux et
quelquefois à des dizaines de kilomètres
de paris
j'ai connu - des vieux qui ont qui
acheter leur pain à la même boulanger
pendant cinquante 50 ans 60 envoyé qui
ont dû partir et qui en souffrent
[Musique]
oh
qui
[Musique]
un bâton paris charles antoine
et
[Musique]
j'aime bien et café j'aime bien les
cafés c'est la forme de vie sociale
normale dans nos climats ici en
particulier dans ce lieu si
c'est probablement le quartier où je me
suis senti le plus dans mon assiette le
plus contents de famille ah non quelle
horreur beaucoup mieux que ça dans un
village exactement le village c'est
chaque quartier au service qu'on a dit
que paris était une collection de
village c'est vrai mais l'arrière des
villages vont se snobe il ya des
villages ou en ce cra va tout on se fait
la gueule ou en ce gourmand ici c'est un
village où on est soi-même
reichert et j'étais l'axé
ah les gens
allez
allez faire attention
les mails y en a très important
la wii elle face comment qui fait mais
bon là le plus ancien du club ici
c'était de mon île à 90 ans et le
monsieur qui a n'a pas varié qui a 12
ans qui marche 82 ans et il a tous les
après midi
d'ailleurs lui c'est le monsieur là bas
qui va jouer qui est un blouson aussi
qu'à une casquette lui il a 79 ans il va
voir 80's aurait en plus c'est lui qui
fait jardinier ici il s'occupe du
terrain est avec nous ici il ya le vice
président qui est la casquette qui à 79
ans aussi
il ya ici un espagnol 80 travail en
france il a 73 ans à peine s'ils parlent
le français pourtant la passer toute sa
vie en france 74 et avec les fit passer
voilà de quoi ils vous ai parlé après
tout les anciens qu'il ya ici en fin d
année un peu respectables avait parlé il
ya ici de grands monsieurs là bas vous
savez avec la veste la dent 74
envoyer des boules ça conserve
[Musique]